So we're going to need one more
interesting property of this operator
B1, but this one is specific to
the context of policy iteration.
So let's think about it this way.
Imagine we've got some policy, Pi1,
just like we've been saying, and
associated with Pi1 is the operator B1.
And let's say that Q1 Is
the fixed point of B1 and
how do we know that it
has a unique fixed point?
>> because you proved it earlier.
>> Yeah,
it was the contraction property of B1.
>> Yeah.
>> So let's imagine that's happened.
We have solved out Q1,
and this is sort of how policy
iteration works too, right?
You start off with the policy, you
get the value function of that policy
then we're going to take the greedy
policy Pi2 with respect to Q1.
So in the last slide or so Pi1 and
Pi2 were just arbitrary policies.
Now Pi2 is specifically
the greedy policy
with respect to the value
function defined by Pi1.
So then let B2 be the operator
associated with Pi2 and
this is the thing that we want to show.
The Q function that comes from solving,
for the the fixed point of Pi1,
so the value function for Pi1 is less
than or equal to B2 applied to Q1.
Does that make sense?
So if we take whatever we end
up with after we solve for
the value function for Pi1, we take
Pi2s greedy policy and then we do one
Bellman backup with respect to that and
we get value function that dominates Q1.
>> Okay, and that's because
of other stuff on the slide.
>> Yeah so we'll just work through that.
So intuitively what we're saying is you
do policy evaluation on Pi1 we get some
value function Q1 and
then we do one step of
essentially value iteration using
the greedy policy with respect to Q1 and
that's going to make it
no worse possibly better.
And so the reason for
that is well what is Q1.
Q1, it's the fixed point
of the B1 operator.
So in this particular case it's
the reward plus the discounted
expected value for taking action Pi1 and
ending up in some new state as prime and
taking action Pi1 of S
prime from that state.
But think about what Pi2 is.
We can actually substitute Pi2 for
Pi1 in here but Pi2 is the greedy
policy with respect to this.
In other words,
it is the policy that causes this
exact quantity to be maximized.
That's what the greedy policy does.
At every state either we're going to
do no worse than we did with Pi1, or
we might actually do better
by switching to Pi2,
the greedy policy with respect to Q1.
So at each state action pair we're
doing no worse by doing one step of,
well, one Bellman backup with B2 on Q1.
So this is exactly
the result that we get.
That the Q function that we
had before is less than or
equal to the Q function that we had
before pushed through the B2 operator.
The Bellman operator with respect to
the greedy policy with respect to Q1.
Essentially the idea is if we are going
to do one more update on Q1, and
we are going to do that update with
respect to a policy that we know is
greedy with respect to Q1,
then we are moving up in the world.
>> Oh, I see, I see, I see, okay.
>> What?
>> Well, no, I was sitting there
thinking well shouldn't this be greater
than or equal to and
then I think, oh no,
I see,
I was kind of reading it backward.
>> Yeah, I wanted to write it as,
because domination up to this point we
used greater than or equal to, but
it just didn't feel right to put it
this way because it would have been
B2 applied to Q1 is greater than or
equal to Q1, which is true, but
the ordering feels backwards to me.
So this seems better,
that we're going to take Q1, we're
going to apply the B2 operator to it,
and it's going to make things better.
>> Write it the other way and
see what happens.
>> Sure.
>> So, when I look at that,
that says that applying the greedy
operator to Q1 makes it
better than it was before.
>> All right, so
that is more helpful for you read,
that's really the same thing.
So that's great.
>> Oh no, it is the same thing.
I just realized the whole time
you were talking I had been
flipping the thing in my head.
>> Sorry about that.
>> Oh no, no, it's not your fault.
>> So
now we have all the pieces we need.
We had one property,
we called it monotonicity.
What, we should call this
property something, too.
Value improvement.
>> Okay.
>> So now with value improvement and
other stuff like definition of Pi2 and
B1 and
B2 and Q1 and Q2 and
the monotonicity property,
we should have all the things
we need to prove that
policy iteration moves
in the right direction.
That it actually improves the policy.
Or, in the case where
the policy's already optimal,
it can't improve it, but
it doesn't break it.
It leaves it the same.
>> It doesn't ever make it worse.